we were talking about heroes a bit
off-camera and you had talked about how
your desire to create or show a certain
type of hero was very important to you
yeah you talked about what that is and
and what does a hero
represent to you in storytelling so yeah
my fascination with it it was with with
the hero figure it didn't start like
with with comic books and superheroes it
really started with action heroes and
martial arts and growing up as a young
kid studying Chinese martial arts I was
a huge fan of action cinema and by the
time I reached maybe 15 is when it
really struck me I you know I realized
that all my heroes were Asian you know
and I was like wow like I'm doing the
same martial arts but none of them look
like me you know and so yeah that's
really when my journey started as far as
I'm making cuz I made a vow that I would
create platforms where I could showcase
heroes that look like me but I fought
like them you know and that was sort of
where like my filmmaking journey started
right then I just felt like I wanted to
see more heroes that reflected the way I
looked up there on the screen and it was
it was never like exclusively that you
know exclusively my image but I just
wanted to see I guess more but even
playing few like More Heroes that
reflected myself and my friends and so
yeah that's sort of where it came from
for me the idea of a hero like a person
who would fight for what they believed
in and fight for the right things and
protect the people they love and protect
the world and someone who was like
righteous and an upstanding and you know
who had sort of all those qualities that
I felt were like important you know
things that were instilled in me as well
and yeah so that's kind of I guess where
that started and even even up until now
I felt like I wanted to contribute to
that I wanted to contribute to the idea
of now that the superhero genre is so
big like it's sort of taken over
everything and I get a lot of
discussions now a lot of a lot of like
people focusing on like more
inclusiveness
I guess across the board and all genres
and and it's interesting now I feel like
audiences are more vocal about it and
they're sort of ready to see more
representation of female superheroes
superheroes of color
every race every Creed and yeah I didn't
want to be one of those people who just
sort of complained about it I wanted to
do my part and sort of contribute to it
and that's sort of where Wonder Studios
comes from run their Studios it's like a
division of my company shadow motion
pictures and that division is going to
be sort of solely for like films in the
superior honor and sci-fi genre yeah
what about the character flaws and
heroes today that are acceptable or
maybe even embraced versus decades ago
have we evolved in terms of allowing
these superheroes to have more character
flaws I think so I think I think because
we've been exposed to a lot
I think I think one back in the 90s and
you know 80s and 90s that sort of thing
that was a very black-and-white sort of
this is what heroes this is what a
villain is you know that sort of thing
and I think I'm because we're being
we've been exposed to so much more
material through streaming platforms
through television and movies we're
getting a lot more I'm noticing things
that are a lot more raw a lot more
gritty and we're sort of seeing
[Music]
characters that to me feel more human
because they're they're gray you know
they're shades of gray and to me it's a
more realistic depiction of what a hero
could be because I feel like everyone
has shades of gray there's certain times
when things really happen in our lives
and we may get angry or but we're still
a good person but you know we may react
in a negative way or whatever the case
is and yeah I feel like social media I
feel like just media in general sort of
impacted these stories and we're seeing
a lot more anti-heroes and you know
we're seeing a lot more shades of gray
which is is much more interesting and
sort of the cardboard cutout sort of
hero because it's harder to relate to
that idea because nobody's black and
white and nobody is perfect you know and
so I think that's why people relate to
Batman more than Superman I think that's
why Batman is more it's probably a
little more popular than Superman
because Superman is more of an idea than
a tangible sort of it's hard to come
done the humor level with Superman you
know because he's you know he's like a
god and he doesn't do anything wrong you
know what I mean so whereas with Batman
like all of the reasons he became a hero
was sort of born out of pain and loss
and he's angry and he's isolated and you
know all these things like people I
think relates him more yeah I like
Batman more too so I think that's one of
those are the reasons why though do you
think as a culture we're almost
distrustful of quote-unquote heroes or
figures that are too perfect in this day
and age yeah I think we immediately
don't buy into it like if you know cuz
there's no one's perfect you know if
we're talking about a human being they
can't be perfect so it's the minute the
worst sort of presented with that idea
we're like we're looking for things that
are wrong we're looking for you know
like we're looking for the truth I guess
yeah so I yeah that's how I feel about I
just there is no perfect person and
anyone who presents themselves that way
is not to be trusted for sure what we're
in an age now where let's let's dig up
some dirt on this person not not saying
that that's the right thing to do it
almost seems like that's where we've
gone it's become acceptable let's find
an old photo let's find an old tweet
let's try to get somebody on their dance
floor and make them look bad in public
something I mean it's become part of of
what we see every day in the news and on
Twitter and yeah absolutely so it would
seep into storytelling yeah and I think
I think that's that's a dangerous
approach I think because I like it I
like in social media to like a Sims like
like a live-action Sims game
where people have so do these lives that
they've created and they're sort of
living through these avatars and you
know I've always felt that like the
bigger social media got the more
antisocial people became like because
you rarely see people in person outside
of some type of event especially like
when it comes to the industry like
people rarely spend any time together
anymore like outside of a film event or
a premiere or some type of something
like that but just to see each other
like you're not gaining any other thing
from it other than just you know having
that relationship and spending time and
being close and that sort of thing and I
think that's been lost quite a bit
because of the way that social media is
sort of operates like them you know and
that's why you have people who are very
awkward socially because they they never
they never see anyone you know it's
easier to sort of be more outspoken and
to have a certain personality when it's
online because there's no physical
there's no physical connection there
it's you know and I remember growing up
and all the time you see your friends
you'd have to go outside and hang out
and be outside all day and you know you
saw people every day and that's how you
built those relationships and um and
yeah now it's very rare that that
happens and so I think even because
being a writer I think like your life
experiences help you but if you're if
most of what you're experiencing is like
through the web it's like what is you
know where does it come from now like
what it is where it is
you know how much of yourself are you
really putting into your stories or you
know I think you can lose a bit of that
genuine sort of part of yourself that is
so important in storytelling like and it
becomes more of data like what you pull
from the world or what you pull from the
internet and you know maybe maybe not so
much of anything you've experienced but
just just information what you think is
going to work but it's if it's not
coming from a genuine place then do
people really connect with your art oh
no you know what I mean like I'm not
sure I know for me personally I always
try to put something of myself like some
personal part of me in every film like I
could probably look at every movie I've
made and look at that storyline and it's
gonna be some reflection of my life some
kind of way something I went through
[Music]
yeah because even I think is that
William Gibson cyberpunk rider like
Neuromancer and those different books
about the cyber world he says he's
actually not a technophile he's actually
the opposite and you would think that
that would not be the case since that's
what he's writing about yeah that just
so sort of the need for human connection
in terms of developing a story and you
know it is lost and maybe people gain it
from creating Berner accounts and then
they try to get reactions from people
and maybe that's they can sort of see
human emotion is pushing buttons online
which definitely there's places for that
but that's a good point in terms of
being able to go out and just connect
with people now even when you see them
there's a phone in their hand
you're not really connecting yeah yeah
you see like you go to lunch with
someone and their heads and the phone
the whole time you know or everybody at
the table they're everybody's head is in
the phone and then they'll they'll eat
and then when they're done eating their
heads are back on the phone and it's
just like there's so much going on
around you but no one's paying attention
to it you know it's just interesting
like like that's the way people wake up
the minute they open their eyes they
start reaching for the phone you know
before they can even see clearly you
know they've already reached for their
phone and then trying to see what they
missed what they missed you know and
whether it's real or not yeah and then I
mean I it's I'm afraid to see what the
futures gonna look like they'll probably
just get chips implanted and be online
24 hours even when they sleep I don't
know
you